I'm not sure
yeah seven long minutes until you're
supposed to start right
oh yeah yeah okay
[Music]
so it's safer not to well I'll turn it
on if there are questions okay yeah are
you gonna announce for it oh yeah I will
I'll come back in a sec
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
um
foreign
is
you can do it
I thought I was gonna have to reset the
openness
everything
okay okay
and
then
morning
all right welcome to day two of the
workshop
um
if you have a question during the talk
raise your hand I will try and get the
mic to you so we can everyone can hear
you and the video can hear you
um so we're gonna kick it off today with
a talk by Robert Huang and he's going to
tell us about learning from Quantum
experiments
um it's a pleasure to be here to talk
about
recently emerging subfield which I
terminated called learning from Quantum
experiments my name is Robert and
yeah and let's just get started
so as many of you know one of the
central goal of science is to learn how
the physical world operates in
particular by performing experiments
humans can receive information about the
physical world and then process that
information to form predictive models
that allows us to make accurate
prediction about how the physical world
will behave under different scenarios
so in order to accelerate an ultimate
scientific development it is very
important to understand how to design
better algorithm to learn from
experiments so I think this is sort of a
more broader topic people in biology
biology do it chemistry Do It
um but here today I'm going to talk
about sort of an emerging and burgeoning
field and Quantum information theory
that considers the task of learning from
Quantum experiments
so the outly of today's talk would be
given as follows in the first part I
would just talk about the basic settings
and some of the example tasks that we
care about in the second part I'll talk
about sounds the key ideas and at the
end I would finish with some Outlook and
open questions
so that's begin with the first part of
the talk
so the basic setting is in in this field
is very simple there's an unknown
Quantum object so it could be a Quantum
state it could be a Quantum process
Quantum Dynamics or it give you
something even more crazier such as an
entire face diagram so for people that
are not familiar with face diagram what
that means is basically you have some
parameters that you can control and that
parameter corresponds to a class of
hamiltonians which corresponds to some
physical system and then you care about
say the ground state of the hamiltonian
so you have some parameters and the
corresponding ground state that's a much
broader object than just a state it's a
function from parameters to the state
space
and the goal is to learn that object
from experiments so so that it becomes
approximately known
and the key question that we care about
is how many experiments are needed in
order to approximately learn this
unknown object so we care about the
sample and query complexity that's the
two main complexity measure that we care
about in in this research line
and one of the goal of this line of
research is to provide a foundation a
learning theoretic foundation for
various applications including Quantum
benchmarking Quantum machine learning
Quantum sensing machine learning for
physics noise characterization
variational Quantum algorithm Etc
and so now in order to start diving into
um sort of what are some basic example
of this so this is just a basic setting
it's very general and very vague and I
wanted to talk about some specific
examples that people have studied
extensively
the first example is what we call
Quantum State tomography there's an
unknown cubic Quantum State described by
a density metrics and the goal is to
learn a classical description row Hat by
performing measurements on multiple
copies of this state row such that after
learning
um we want this description row hat to
be approximately equal to row say under
the trace Norm so the trace Norm
basically means that for any observable
with the spectral Norm bounded by one
the
the state row hat would have the similar
property as Rome
so what are some motivation for studying
these questions
um I think one of the main motivation is
that this is one of the simplest Quantum
learning problems that one could think
about
um so by understanding this I think it
illustrates a lot of different aspects
in terms of learning about Quantum
systems and learning from Quantum
experiments and another more practical
motivation for considering this is to
Benchmark Quantum system so
experimentalists often creates some kind
of mini body system in their lab and
they wanted to know what is this
particular system that they have created
and by performing Quantum State
tomography the experimentalist can at
least verify or understand what's the
state that they have been created so
there's a long list of works that look
at Quantum State tomography
here's just a few references
um
people started by looking at wickner
function in order to do Quantum State
demography there are so-so methods based
on compressed sensing and then more
recently actually that's already like
six years ago Ryan O'Donnell John Wright
John ha and other people they've cooked
up the optimal protocol for doing
Quantum seismography it's optimal in the
sense of sample complexity so it uses
the minimal number of samples that is
number of copies of the state in order
to learn about this real hand
so however
um due to the sort of a strict method of
Trace Norm
um performing Quantum State tomography
has a complexity of the scales
exponentially in the system size
so in practice you can only do Quantum
State tomography for very small system
like maybe a system less than 10 cubits
I think seven or eight is the maximum
people have gone to
so in order to circumvent this
exponential scaling there's another very
related task which is called Shadow
tomography scatter instant um
um proposed sort of this task
it's very similar to the quantum
statement it's very similar to Quantum
State demography the only difference is
in how you measure success so in Quantum
systemography we measure success by
constructing this representation row hat
that is equal to row that is
approximately equal to real under Trace
Norm here we relax that condition we
don't care about Trace Norm that we care
about
um
say a set of observables a 1 0 m and we
only want the description to be accurate
for this set of observables so this
could be a very large set M could be
very very large
um however it's not all sets uh all
observables because if you care about
all the variables then that would be the
same as Quantum seismography so here we
usually consider this capital M to be
something say exponential and system
size or or something like that in
general the number of observable skills
doubly exponential in in the system size
so
since it's very similar to Quantum State
demography I would say this is sort of
the second most basic Quantum learning
problem so that's one motivation for
looking into Shadow demography and
understand its complexity
and another more practical one similar
to before is The Benchmark Quantum
system such that you have a much better
scaling in system size we'll show I'll
talk briefly that the complexity scales
much more favorably
and furthermore
by having an efficient methods for
constructing a classical orientation for
any Quantum State you allow sort of a
nice inter interplay between the quantum
world and the classical world so
Sean tomography has now become sort of a
basic primitive in various hybrid
Quantum classical algorithms so that's
another motivation for considering
Shadow tomography for understanding the
complexity of such a task and starting
out in actually 2018
um shout out to Mark if you have Quantum
state by Scott erinson and then
following um by multiple people that try
to improve upon it such as costume
badescu and Ryan O'Donnell's work on
improved Quantum data analysis our work
on predicting many properties of a
Quantum system from very few
measurements
um
we have now sort of understands the
complexity for the sample complexity for
doing shout out to Market
particular in under the most general
setting the complexity scales linearly
in system size rather than exponentially
in system science and in certain cases
such as in the settings that we have
looked at it's the complexity is
actually independent in the system size
so now you have this very efficient way
to learn about a Quantum system
to be clear the sample complexity is
still not pinned down that's true that's
true so it's not entirely clear that
this is linear I'm just saying the upper
bound is linear
um we don't really have a lower bound
that's actually has to be linear and
there are cases could it be independent
of system size in general
right
yes it is it's been done yeah I should
have yeah I was about to say that um um
dependence on M is also very mild in the
sense that it's usually say logarithmic
and M or poly logarithmic in them we
also haven't pinned down the complexity
yet
that's the second example and now I
wanted to switch here and talk about the
third example so there's a lot of
different examples that we wanted to
perform learning another very common
example is called palichana democracy
um here rather than having it on the
quantum State you have an unknown value
chart so for people that are not
familiar basically channel is just means
that you have some probability
distribution over penalty errors that is
tensor product of X Y and Z or identity
so this is a very important task
um that arises in say error correction
and filter and Quantum computation Etc
so usually there's an unknown uncupid
Pali Channel p and we wanted to learn a
description for p by preparing input
States evolving under this poly Channel
and measuring the output state such that
after learning we have a description
that's close to P under the diamond Norm
so the motivation for this as I briefly
mentioned is to characterize Quantum
noise in Quantum devices and after
learning about the quantum noise it
could be very useful for performing
better Quantum error correction or
during error mitigation Etc
there's also a long list of works that
study this problem starting from
siflamia and Joe wilman's work on
efficient estimation of poly channels
and then there's a lot of other
developments that have gone throughout
the years
the complexity is a little bit more
um it varies so in general when you just
have a Pali channel the complexity still
scales exponentially in system size
however people often make certain
assumptions about the sparsity of the
error or certain locality assumption and
making that assumption often makes the
complexity much better and in many cases
it could be say logarithmic in N or
polynomial
the final example I want to talk about
is predicting ground States again
another very different example here
instead of having an unknown state or an
unknown Quantum process we have unknown
function that Maps parameters to the
ground state of some hamiltonian hfx so
you can think of it as there's an
unknown phase diagram for the entire
sort of physical system entire set of
physical systems it's not just a single
physical system and we could learn this
F Hat by say preparing ground States
under different parameters and then
measuring the state so after learning
um given a new input X we can predict
what the ground state of that
hamiltonian is
so this line of work is not actively not
really actively studied and in a more
theoretical fashion but it has garnered
a lot of interest from a more practical
side starting from Giuseppe carlio and
Matthias striers paper on solving the
quantum antibody problems with
artificial neural networks to this icml
paper on neural message passing for
quantum chemistry there's a lot of
excitement about using machine learning
or learning approaches or learning
algorithm in order to
um in order to speed up computation of
say ground States or computation and
quantum chemistry and quantum physics
for example this paper
um by Justin Gilmer and other
collaborators I think has a lot about
like 4 000 citations
um at the moment
yeah just uh could could you um could
you see whether the the difficulty here
or the central issue here is the unknown
F or the or the nature of the ground
state yeah I think both both are hard
um so
even if you completely know F that this
process can still be very hard right
like in general
and so can can you can you say
physically what what's the relevance of
f uh you know how do you think about it
yeah so I think it's like like in a
physical setup you have some parameters
you can control and you might not really
know when you control that parameter
like say you tune the lasers or you you
modify a certain aspect of your device
how the actual physical system is
generated so in that case it would be
kind of unknown um of course you can
assume that is known I think that's
usually what people in hamiltonian
complexity consider the problem but here
you can also say what if we don't know
like we just have parameters like the
experimentalists can tune those
parameters to create different materials
under different circumstances can we
understand and make prediction about the
ground state
I mean presumably this problem of
predicting a phase diagram goes back
earlier than 2017 right yes yes
definitely
yes
yeah these aren't just like more like
where people explicitly use machine
learning algorithms for doing it
and and yeah these are just four
examples I think there's a lot more
examples that you can just picture a
problem and then because I think all
problems contain some aspects of
learning about it on no object and you
can just pick your problem and then and
then put it into this and then
rigorously study using learning
theoretic tools I think there's always
going to be something interesting that's
going to happen and here are just uh a
lot more problems that people have been
asking me about some of them are kind of
crazy like the fourth one but there are
also some more concrete I think the
first question that I'm personally very
interested in is understanding what kind
of quantum circuits or what kind of
quantum algorithm can we actually learn
in the sense that there are some unknown
Quantum circuit and then you wanted to
learn it you wanted to be able to learn
it so that you can mimic that or make
prediction about it which I think is a
very important question in Quantum
machine learning and variational Quantum
algorithms there's also questions such
as what aspect of an unknown Quantum
machine is learnable I think in
childhood we would be talking about that
question quite bit later
there's also a question about how to
learn a good Quantum sensor given some
unknown Quantum machine how can we learn
the noise in order to throw it away and
then get a good sensor out of it and
then the first question surprisingly
there's a lot of people asking me that
and I don't know how to answer it this
kind of learning algorithm discover new
physics I think this is a question that
many physicists want to know but I have
no idea how to how to solve it
and here then these are just a bunch of
examples and sort of questions that can
be studied in this field and now I
wanted to talk about some of the key
ideas that people have developed
throughout the past several years in
order to tackle some of these learning
problems and the talk would be sort of
now would be separated into two parts
the first part will focus on upper
bounds that is how to design good
learning algorithms and the second part
will be focused on Lower bounds showing
that no good algorithms exist
so I'm going to start with the first
part
um the sort of a recurring theme that
people have been considering in the past
several years on a
um in in terms of Designing a good
learning algorithm
um consists of these four components in
General on the algorithmic side people
um have proposed of using randomized
experiments
um to gather the data and then follow by
a proper data processing and on analysis
side for analyzing the performance of
The Learning algorithm is it's kind of
closely related to how people do
learning theory basically you use sort
of the geometry of your unknown object
you try to learn to perform some kind of
geometric analysis to understand its
sort of um like for example BC Dimension
or flat shattering Dimension it's one
example of that and then utilize
concentration inequalities to
um to show that after some number of
experiments you can converge to the
right thing so these are the sort of the
four key techniques that people often
use and in order to
provide a bit more context to these four
techniques I think it would be nice if
we can dive a little bit into
um this task Shadow tomography which I
feel like it's one of the most basic
Quantum learning tasks and we call it
that the task basically you have an
unknown uncupid State and you wanted to
learn this state by performing
measurements such that after learning
you can utilize this learn description
draw hat to predict many up Circles
so now I would like to talk a little bit
about how how these four components come
into
so in terms of the randomized
experiments one way of Performing Shadow
tomography is to do the following first
you sample a random Clifford from
uniformly from the Clifford group and
then apply it onto your Quantum State
row so you rotate it and then after
rotation you just measure the state in
the computational basis to obtain a bit
string bi
so what this randomized experiment is
doing you can think of it as it's uh the
quantum state is just a high dimensional
object and then
every time you sample a random Clifford
and then do measurement it's kind of
like you're looking at this High
dimensional object from different angle
and getting a classical Shadow or
classical snapshot of the outcome and
then you just perform this very simple
randomized experiment for multiple times
and and that's it so that's the
randomized experiments
and now what you do is during the data
processing is to construct for each of
the experiments say experiments I you
construct this representation row hat I
given as follows
there's this uh two to the N plus one
which is a quite a large number
multiplied to this U dagger bibiui and
then minus identity
so you can do that completely
classically because um UI dagger bi
that's just a stabilizer State and you
can store that very efficiently on
classical computer
so so yeah that's the randomized
experiment and that's the data
processing and now through the geometry
of Clifford unitary basically the fact
that it forms uh unitary three design
you can show that the expectation value
of of trace of O row hat I basically the
thing you constructed during data
processing for any observable o
um that subscript of I be inside the
parentheses yes yes
thank you
um yeah so the expectation value of that
would be equal to
um the the the true property for the
unknown State role so we recall that
this row is unknown here and then the
observable o is the property you know
and you want it to predict it and
furthermore using the three design
property of Clifford unitary you can
show that the variance of this
estimation would be less than equal to
three times the forbidia storm squared
of the observable o
so together with these two facts um
which which com which stems from the
geometry of Clifford unitary you can
show that for any given observables o1
to om
um such that it's forbidia storm say
it's bounded by a constant
after performing a logarithmic number of
measurements You can predict trace of OI
role for all of these observables up to
some constant actors so so what do you
actually do do you average the row I had
yeah so um because you only get this
first two moments so you do medium of
mean estimation instead of just
averaging yeah yes like the center
technique um that that you do when you
only get the second moment bounded you
don't have higher moments so you cannot
just do
um concentration so yeah so that's a
sort of a very simple illustration on
how these four components play in this
it's it's a it's a it's called classical
Shadow tomography um the true shallow
tomography is much more complicated than
this but but yeah and the difference is
that this requires the frobenius
enormous object yes yes but it's also a
simpler procedure to do experimentally
yes okay and but wait wait a minute so
like what you would store in memory
would be the list of all the real I hats
yes and then when you've given some new
data that you want to predict then you
do the calculation and then you take the
median of mean of the scalar numbers
that you get out yes thank you yes
it's a very simple procedure but I think
it nicely illustrates it's one of the
four techniques that was used in very
various different contexts such as in
poly Channel tomography and bladder
so yeah so through that for your
components you get the theorem which
states that given two parameters B and
Epsilon the procedure that I just talked
about can learn a classical
representation of an unknown Quantum
state by performing B log M over Epsilon
Square measurement such that
subsequently given any observables or 1
0 m with a forbidia storm bounded by b
or media Zone squared bounded by B the
procedure can predict all of these
expectation value up to Epson error so
for example if you have 10 to the six
different observables you wanted to
predict oauth which has a province Norm
bounded by one naively if you just
measure each of the observable one by
one you need 10 to the 6 over Epsilon
Square measurement but now this theorem
tells us that we only need 6.10 over
Epsilon squared measurement
yeah there's some intuition what kind of
Observer observables have small
forbidius number yeah that's a great
question uh actually for myself so
mentioned it so so it's usually small
for like low rank observable and one of
the application is estimating Fidelity
so suppose you wanted to create say a
safe side or you want to check uh which
which state you're you have created then
usually you wanted to estimate say
um the inner product between this uh cat
bra side and the state roll and then
that will be an example where you can
simultaneously SME
multiple of these Fidelity and actually
you can estimate an exponential number
of fidelities by performing a polynomial
number of experiments
and this is just a one theorem when you
utilize cliffer unitary to do randomized
experiments you can modify that
randomized experiments you can use some
other random unitary ensemble in order
to rotate your system and by changing
that Ensemble you actually can slightly
change the theorem basically for a
different example for different
randomized experiments you will get a
different norm and and in particular for
a Clifford unitary you get the forbinia
storm but if you use say like single
qubit local unitary rotation then you
would get another Norm that scales
differently than for business so more
generally you get this theorem where you
have this what we call a shadow norm and
as long as your observable has a
boundary Shadow Norm You can predict it
and that Norm depends on the randomized
experiments that one performs
so that sort of Fab one of the in my
mind one of the simplest
Quantum learning
algorithm that one could have
and utilizing these four ideas by
constructing the right randomized
experiment doing the proper the
corresponding data processing and doing
the right analysis there's a lot of
other applications that people have come
up with throughout the past several
years here's a long list of references
but for example people have proposed
using random experiments to do
cross-platform verification basically
that just means
using two quantum computers you create
two states say row and row Prime you
wanted to check if they are the same
state for example so you wanted to say
estimate the inner product so
Andreas Alban and people and Peter
Zola's group have worked on it there's a
paper published at PRL and unreal gun
shoe zephalandel and winchelli we also
have worked on the in the title called
in a paper title called distributed
Quantum inner product estimation where
they try to understand what's the best
way of doing cross-platform verification
so that's one application there's also
other applications
or something actually yeah it's actually
here I uh at least for the two paper
Dimension they look at the inner product
the inner product of what though you
mean yeah it would be kind of small or
what yeah yes
and then you divide it by like the
purities square root okay
so that's one application
um there's other applications such as
characterizing topological order like
for example there's that sort of people
aren't familiar but uh people have heard
but there's these people have created
topological states in the lab for
example in Google Sycamore computer
um and in order to in order to really
characterize that I have created a
typological order State they actually
utilize randomized experiments in order
to estimate certain quantities that can
characterize this such as the
topological entanglement entropy
and similarly one can also utilize these
techniques to probe entanglement entropy
in their systems or diagnose Quantum
chaos or learn Quantum noise Etc
and there's actually much more examples
and we have written a sort of a short
review randomized measurement toolbox
that
presented more of these examples
So after talking about sort of the
theorem and some of the other
applications the question that people
ask me quite a lot of times is why are
we doing randomized experiments why
don't we
carefully design a good set of
experiments and then potentially after
doing some set of experiments after
getting the data we modify how we do the
next set of experiments adaptively and
so on it seems like that would be much
better than doing this very simple form
of randomized experiments where you just
randomly sample unitary and then perform
random measurements
um
my first answer to them is that in many
cases you can prove that doing
randomized experiments is actually
asymptotically optimal
um you may you may fail that adaptively
choosing experiments and designing a
good set of experiments is better but in
many cases it does it does not for
example in
the first paper exponential separation
between learning with and without
Quantum memory in that paper we proved
that
um for a wide range of tasks
um doing a randomized experiment is the
best for example some form of Shadow
tomography under the settings
of where you don't do like entangled
measurements you just do single copy
measurement and you can do it adaptively
doing randomized fashion doing
randomized experiments is actually
optimal another more recent one actually
I think it was just a paper yesterday on
tight bounds for State tomography within
coherent measurements they finally
resolved this open question that when
you wanted to do Quantum State
tomography
I'm doing adaptively also doesn't help
um or you like the best thing you can do
asymptotically is just to actually the
same protocol as this you just sample a
random Clifford and then mesha that's
the best way for
um doing Quantum State tomography
when you only allow like single copy
measurements and that gives you like a d
cubed scale yes that gives you a DQ
scaling and if you have entangle
measurements such as the one that John
right has then you get a D Squared scale
and and remind me for shadow tomography
with incoherent measurements do we know
lower bounds it's like better than than
for the general case
what do you mean the general cases well
I mean I mean for you know if you're
allowed to make income hearing
measurements then yes then our well
we're bound this is is is is pretty poor
it just log of M right but it but if if
if you if you're restricted to
incoherent measurements yes then then do
we know anything better yeah it's
actually yeah so that's actually what we
show in in this first paper
um so in this exponential separation
between learning with and without
Quantum memory we showed that
when you wanted to do Shadow tomography
um for a general like spectral Norm like
the thing you did
um and you only restrict yourself to
doing single copy measurements then you
can prove that number of experiments you
need is is scales linearly in them
so you cannot do better than just uh
measure each of them
so that's sort of my optimize is that
even with adaptivity yes yes that's
really nice
so so yeah so the first result
um yeah so the first answer to that
question was kind of it's not a very uh
intuitive answer but the second two
hopefully provides some more intuition
the first is that by doing randomization
it can term bad events into low
probability events and that's actually
already happening in this procedure to
see that when you're when we're
constructing this row hat eye we have
this exponentially large number multiply
in front so if you choose a very very
bad observable
um by looking at what you get here then
you can actually make the estimation
extremely bad exponentially bad even
um so so basically by sampling a random
Clifford unitary you can avoid this um
fast scenarios basically by turning that
into a very low probability event for
that case you turn it into a
exponentially low probability event I'm
I'm sorry but could you give any
intuition for why you multiply
by this enormous
and then subtract I like yeah
the intuition is that when you implement
the random cliffer that's because it's
uh
it's really rotating in a very wild
sense in the unitary group so so after
that when you have this UI dagger vibiui
it's it's going to be quite orthogonal
to anything you wanted to predict
so like whenever you have an observable
you want the British um it would be
quite orthogonal to it so you have to
like rescale it back by that exponential
number so it looks kind of dangerous but
actually actually
um in practice it will work and Steve
flamia and Sean Ray Chen and other
people and from China they actually
proved that even if your if even if
there is noise in your device like for
example there's some unknown noise
there's some noise that in your random
Clifford that you're applying
um
using site modification of that formula
would also work so so it's actually
quite robust in practice with that I
mean if you increase the number of
samples you take though because
uh
but yeah and when you take more samples
then then this this constraint
essentially that's like a normal
constraint so when you take more samples
so now your B becomes larger so then you
yes you can grow the normal
director
oh because you're arguing that your key
if I pick us home or simple in some
sense then you're
then you're ah I see I see
you have a place you're covering kind of
a space then somebody might
I see icic yeah but actually I think uh
okay so first of all here you can see
that there's no two to the end coming in
the theorem statement so it's kind of
just
I would say uh inside the calculation
there's this it pops up
um so I don't think this is that this is
not bad at all it's just a little bit
surprising that this is there
um and and regarding what you said
um I think it's true but it requires you
to take an exponential number of
experiments so that you actually cover
it up
foreign
[Music]
yeah that's just a fixed number
um if you don't you don't really care
about what the observables are you just
always multiply it by two to the N plus
one
to some numerical restabilities when you
try to run it ah I see yeah so one has
to be a little bit careful on the
numerical side in order to circumvent
certain numericals
Yeah so basically you you you have to
like usually if you just encode it into
floating points
um it's limited by some number so you
have to at least when I was implementing
it I I cut it up so that I represent
these factors in uh like it's like this
big number like you just represent the
floating point in an array and things
like that so there's ways to me okay
yeah and then in addition to
randomization Turning bad scenarios into
low probability events if your
information is distributed quite evenly
in sort of different experiments than by
doing Monte Carlo sampling they can
quickly converge to
um to the right thing kind of similar to
how people do multicolonial integration
which doesn't have a dimension
dependence and so on
so that's that's it for the first part
and then I would like to dive into the
second part that is proving no good
learning algorithms exists so why do we
wanted to do that
um in particular here we're going to
focus on conventional experiments
and
and it will become clear why we wanted
to do this for conventional experiments
so what I mean by conventional
experiments is basically sort of an
abstract model for what science is
currently do in the lab we model the
scientists abstractly as a classical
agent shown by this gray robot that can
receive process and stored constant
information basically you can receive
constant information by doing
measurements process it using classical
computation and storing them in a
classical memory and together the Costco
agent can utilize these classic
information to make prediction about
what kind of property does this unknown
Quantum object has and so on
however as Quantum technology start to
evolve we can imagine what a future
experiments could be like where we have
a Quantum agent instead of a classical
agent so the quantum agent receive
process historic Quantum information
that is it can we assume that utilizing
Advanced Quantum technology we can use
quantum sensor to retrieve Quant
information process it using Quantum
computation and storing them in Quantum
memory and together the quantum agent
can utilize Quantum information to make
prediction about the unknown Quantum
object
and by proving lower bounds for
conventional experiments run by
classical agents it can help us
understand what are the potential
Quantum advantage in learning from
experiments so perhaps in the future we
can utilize a more advanced set of say
Quantum sensor quantum computer and
Quantum memory in order to say better
detect our two massive black holes is
colliding in in the Galaxy so actually
people are already doing that using
Quantum sensors but I think
um but they're it's very rudimentary
Quantum sensor and I think there will be
a lot of opportunities also of
incorporating Quantum memory and quantum
computers into it but in order to really
understand the advantage of using
Quantum technology in these kind of
scientific settings I think it becomes
very important to prove lower bounds for
what we can do in a more conventional
setting
foreign
oh you're asking uh
in in this setting which part am I
getting upon information from or how it
is
yeah
exactly yeah so
for example if are you asking like
practically or more abstractly exactly
I'm actually going to talk about it
so yeah so like like like uh Alex was
asking um it's a little bit back what I
just said so now I wanted to make it
more formal and actually we designed
this mathematical framework to talk
about
um conventional experiments and Quantum
enhance experiments in various settings
it's also called an incoherent setting
and a coherent setting because that
place you cannot you cannot coherently
store Quant information but in here you
can
um
and such a framework has been considered
for example in Blue Book channel in Fox
2020 our previous paper at PRL and also
a harone of Jordan color and xiaolang
sheets paper actually it's now published
at nature communication on Quantum
algorithmic measurements
so in order to illustrate it in a better
way that's considered a simple task of
learning about an unknown physical
system that is an unknown State rope
we assume that there are some physical
sorts that can generate a single copy or
a single sample of row at a time and the
goal is to learn about this state role
so in the conventional setting what we
can do is we can query that physical
source and get a quantum State and then
perform a measurement on the quantum
state in order to obtain some classical
data you can store that classical data
in classical memory and then process
that Costco data to select the next
measurement
and then after selecting the next
measurement you perform the measurement
again obtain data store it process it
and repeat
so this is actually very similar to what
we talked about as the Adaptive kind of
setting where you can adaptively choose
the experiments you do next round and
when you utilize the randomized
experiments you basically remove the
part on processing you just do a
randomized experiment get some data
store it and then do it again you don't
actively choose what you do next
I mean how is this different at all
yeah it's the same it's the same it's
the same it's just a
um
I think more more precisely in the
literature it's also called adaptive
incoherent measurement sure right that's
a single copy measurement but here it
just give it a more
common name for the same thing
so
so now we have this classical memory
that stores all the data from all the
povm measurement outcome we can then
process it and then make prediction
about the physical system bro
on the other hand for the quantum and
hand setting this is basically sort of
the settings that this is more of the
entangled setting so basically what you
can do is you can use quantum sensor to
obtain Quantum information store it in
Quantum memory and then in the next
round you do the same you
use quantum sensor to obtain this
Quantum State sorting Quantum memory and
repeat so at the end you have this
Quantum memory that stores all copies of
row which you process them using Quantum
computation
and then after that you can make
prediction based on the outcome
so that's sort of the more precisely how
the two settings
that clarifies your question
so
here's just a summary between the two
settings
um
in our paper we also call it algorithm
without Quantum memory and algorithm
with Quantum memory because the main
difference between the two cases is
literally
um how whether you have this Quantum
memory that allows you to entangle Quant
information from past and future
experiments
a silly question so can you in the
second case can you partial measurements
to determine the next uh you mean here
yeah you can also you can definitely
answer to that
I think yeah
so now um
yeah so now we can after defining these
two classes we can then analyze all the
possible protocols but algorithm that
the classical and the quantum agent
could do to study their corresponding
learning ability
in particular here's just one example of
an advantage of a type of quantum
advantage that separates the classical
Asian and the quantum agent
here in the task as follows kind of
similar to shout out to Mark repeat
basically the classical or Quantum Asian
will learn the classical model of an
incubate State and such that
after learning
one can utilize this custom model to
predict say the magnitude of an Pali
operator P from this set
and
there's a theorem that was stated
basically it says that a classical agent
would require at least two to the end
experiments to predict just
one address at Rosario Lee chose an
observable from the set the quantum
agent only requires older an experiments
to predict all of the four to the end
observables so this is basically the
separation that you talked about before
for coherence versus incoherent Shadow
tomography but just instantiated to the
polyethylene yes yes yes yes yes yes
this is actually also from the same
paper the exponential separation between
learning with and without content memory
um the result is slightly different
because for Pali observable um say
there's 40 million of them so you you
can set m equal to 4 to the end but now
you can see that the classical agent
only needs 2 to the end that's actually
tight
um so it's only square root n but I
think more but we proved that more
generally it Scales N
so this is a example of a exponential
separation between having a classical
learning agent that only do measurement
versus a Quantum learning agent and the
basic idea underlying this theorem is
that for a classical agent it will be
hindered by uncertainty principle
basically all of these poly operators
are highly non-commutative from one
another so they're incompatible when you
measure
when you get information about some of
the observable you get no information
about the other in a sense so due to
this uncertainty principle it hinders
the ability the learning ability of the
classical Asian on the other hand a
Quantum agent is not hindered by
this type of uncertainty principle
and furthermore this exponential
separation can already be proven
even when we restrict to Quantum state
that have no entanglement basically a
classical distribution over product
State even for that kind of state you
can have this exponential separation
and I'll be a little bit faster on
talking about some of the basic
in the previous result the classical
agent can only work with one copy of
time yes you just measure it to get
classical data right it doesn't make a
difference if the classical Legend can
work with two copies at a time or
something like
yeah that's a great question
um actually for this case
um there's a this exponential separation
is between two copy and one
the quantum agent also just work with
two copies
is there known exponential separation
where the classical agent gets like o1
copies
and still you can mean exponentially
many experiments yes yes we have a paper
of sound
um basically for any K you can construct
a learning problem similar to this one
such that
um that requires an exponential number
of experiments but if you can store all
of them in Quantum memory and then do
measurements uh do like
entangle measurements then you only need
a polynomial number of samples so this
raises the question can you get a sharp
separation where like with K when you
can measure K copies at once you can't
you need exponentially many but if you
can measure K plus one copies at once
then you can do it easily yeah that's a
that's a question that we've
we originally seek out to tackle but
it's it's still open at the moment so
there's not I think there was a paper
that I sort of does something very
similar
um very recently it was on this yeah I
think that was for like uh like a like
Oracle type separation right rather than
a state learning yeah yeah yeah probably
it wasn't quite exactly yeah it wasn't
like State learning but it had like a
function
yes
nobody was shot yes yes I think I know
the paper
uh I think it's so
so I think this one's by uh yeah I think
the two concurrent works one of them was
uh with France was and then there's the
CC Legends
okay all right
[Laughter]
yeah so I just wanted to briefly talk
about sort of the proof strategy
um especially for the lower bound the
upper bound is already shown previously
um yeah and the basic idea is to
basically have a graphical
representation for the memory state of
the classical agent so basically the
classical agent during its learning um
its memory state will change and then we
can just sort of represent it
graphically in particular say we start
from uh root R after one experiment we
will the Costco agent its memory will
transition into different points and
then after a second experiments it will
transition into more points in general
this could be a highly complicated graph
however
um because when there's two knots that
map to the same knots
um like when when this kind of soft
graph happens that means some
information is being lost so when we
focus on the optimal classical learning
agent we can assume that such a subgraph
doesn't exist so to find the tree
representation can be shown
um in this form
yeah so it could be the graphical
representation can be shown to be a
truth
and depending on the underlying State
underlying physical
system that you try to characterize the
transition like the probability
distribution on how the classical agent
will Traverse this tree will be
different
and
if the Costco agent can distinguish the
two physical setting it must mean that
the probability distribution at the
bottom layer must be sufficiently
different and which means that when you
have more experience being done the tree
will be deeper and then at the end the
bottom layer it will be more distinct
so now building on these kind of basic
ideas
um one could turn this prediction task
that I previously talked about into a
distinguishing task and this is sort of
settings where we How We Do It um
basically it will be revealed to be one
poly and then we set up the the unknown
State such that it's for each cases it's
one of a one of the three different
scenarios and then
the prediction task basically
corresponds to a distinguishing task and
we can utilize information through our
tools to prove lower bounds for the
distinguishing task which by reduction
yields a lower Bound for the prediction
task
that's for just a very brief
um
idea on how we establish this
exponential separation
and there's actually a lot of other
examples but currently the proof
technique seems to vary quite
substantially for different tasks
um there's other many other examples
where you get either exponential or
polynomial separation between classical
learning agent and Quantum learning
agent the first example
um go back to anuragan shoes I've landed
in shelio's paper distributed Quantum
inner product estimation where you
wanted to estimate the inner product the
Hilbert Smith inner product between two
states
um it has also recently been shown
actually just yesterday like I said for
Quantum State demography
in our paper we also show an exponential
separation for classifying symmetry
Quantum principle component analysis and
there's a polynomial separation for
Quantum state certification
um for learning how the channel I think
they're so so uh exponential separation
between a classical learning agent and a
Quantum learning region
so yeah so that concludes the second
part of this key idea
um
and the last part I wanted to talk about
self-outlook and open questions
so
throughout the years of development I
think we start to know a little bit
about what we can learn efficiently but
there's still a lot of things that are
very unknown at the moment especially
when we start to move a little bit
closer to the application sorry
particular I think for machine learning
for physics variational Quantum
algorithms and Quantum machine learning
there are still a lot of learning
problems
um that have not been studied very
rigorously yet so I believe that by
building connection or trying to
formalize a lot of these problems that
arises practically
um could be a very sort of fruitful
direction to consider
and finally I want to talk about a few
open questions which are much more
concrete the first question is can we
perform shell tomography on broader
classes of observables computationally
efficiently
so at the moment we know how to do
Shadow tomography for any observable
um with family Spectrum but that's only
simple efficiently rather than
computationally efficiently and if we
include the constraint of being
computationally efficient
we only know how to do it for say low
weight observables or penalty
observables
um I think it's become very important to
understand if it's possible to do share
automography efficiently on broader
classes
and the second question which I've also
mentioned a little bit before is what
causes of quantum Dynamics or Quantum
circuits are actually officially
learnable
there's many natural classes that people
have looked at before but either they're
not efficient and learnable quantumly
for example even just ac0 that's not
officially learnable quantumly or or
they are efficiently learnable
classically for example if you have a
local hamiltonian Dynamics and you
wanted to learn that Dynamics you can
just do some very simple
experiments and you can learn it
classically so I think it's very
important to understand is there if
there's something in between I believe
there are but it's a little bit hard to
find and
we probably need more tools to
understand learning behavior in a
Quantum setting better in order to
answer this question
and finally uh that's the question more
closely related to Quantum benchmarking
that is could we efficiently learn if
there are no local Quantum noise in an
unknown Quantum mission
basically as people know falter and
quantum computers require noise to be
local so if there's no local Quantum
noise we're kind of doomed so can we
experimentally test this by designing a
good learning out version at the moment
I don't think we have a good
approach for learning that so so yeah so
that's it for my talk thank you so much
for listening
[Applause]
thanks for the lovely talk so I want to
just um talk about the first point a
little bit more so the the
procedures you talked about like like
the local poly or the random Clifford
those look like they're officially
implementable right or yes okay good so
what are you talking about here when you
say
um I mean could that seem to have
nothing to do with the observable in
question right there's just a norm bound
on the observable so what do you mean by
being oh yeah but I mean uh in a sense
these Norm bound defines the class
self-help service I see what you mean
okay so I mean but normally if you think
about things like locals like local in
the sense of you know mini body physics
local yes that should be fine right I
mean yes so so what kind of observables
are you aiming for here yeah so I would
say this is theoretically driven
um practically I think many people kind
of just care about low weight
observables where you only act on a few
bodies true in a sense
um let's say for example I mean okay and
then string operator that's kind of a
pal the observable but there could be
some more complicated string operator uh
maybe you wanted to learn them sorry so
so that could be another example of such
so but you mentioned like the Fidelity
for example which is you can do because
um oh so Fidelity um Fidelity depends so
I guess pure State Fidelity yeah so for
example if that if that state is
how to say
I think in general if you just wanted to
okay so that protocol that I mentioned
before that theorem that's also simple
complexity I just talked about
um the number of experiments and
measurements you need rather than a
computational one and for certain
classes of States you can indeed do it
computational efficiently but I think at
the moment it's not clear
um even for just these observables with
boundary for being a storm can you do a
computationally efficiently always okay
but so then as far as like many body
physics are concerned is this like
tomography thermography thing
practically over or is there like sorry
is like tomography basically
efficiently solved now as far as like a
mini body physicist would be concerned
because if you only care about oh
I mean this is the end of the line
somehow I mean
I think for a low weight observables uh
the Improvement will probably yeah for
low observables okay I think it's pretty
clear that we can do it efficiently
um and I think we're kind of quite close
to what we can do optimally yeah but but
when I talk to some physicists they also
mentioned the string operators and some
of them are quite complicated they're
not just Pali observables and they also
said that I wanted to master them and
things like that so I think that's
another sort of Direction
would you provide some intuitions on why
do it adaptively doesn't help is it
possible that we just didn't think hard
enough to find a good adaptive algorithm
Yeah so basically uh the lower bounds
that I mentioned that was proven
um basically says there's no we have
already yeah yeah um
about the intuition yeah I think the
intuition is that
a lot of these learning okay so I think
intuitively adaptive only helps when you
it definitely only helps when you have a
good enough intuition about what the
things you wanted to measure sorry and
then you wanted to just kind of like
pinpoint it
um but a lot of the problems here is
that you start out with having no
information like you don't know what
that unknown object is so when you don't
know what that is you just have to do
something randomly and then basically
what happens is that when you start
doing things randomly at a certain point
you start seeing that oh I start to know
about what this unknown thing is but at
that point you also finished learning so
is it possible that I first do say half
of the measurements that I want to do
and then I already have some idea of
what it is then I can do it in a more
efficient way
I see yeah I think it's possible to
still get constant speed up
um so here this is more it's just saying
that it's symptomatically optimal so
it's possible that you can first do like
half of your experiments you do some
things and then the other half you can
pinpoint it better but that will only
give you a constant see that and and in
a lot of cases that I've talked about
like in child demography like in Quantum
State demography and other tasks what
happens really is that
after you already get enough information
that you can start doing better you also
already know everything in a sense
you're learning terminates
that's very interesting
oh so I mean I mean I mean maybe it
would help to just say that the the
shadow the the coherent measurement
Shadow tomography procedures rely on
gentle measurement right to like not
damage the state by much and keep
repeating over and over for each of the
observables and gentle measurement
requires amplification right and
amplification that's the reason why you
need this coherent measurement so like
you know it would be to me it would be
very surprising if there were a way to
avoid that
oops
thanks for a great talk Robert
um I have a couple more questions I
guess along the lines of like you know
to what extent can we is this like final
or is this like more room for
improvement one example that I thought
of was the this Epsilon Square uh
dependence that you have I think you
proved in some
cases that is like informationally
theoretically optimal or something but
but there are definitely examples where
people have improved into Epsilon
um which I think can be actually quite
important uh because in a physical
experiment you often care about like you
know 10 to the minus three times minus
four epsilons and you know there's a
huge difference between you know that
versus square like you know number of
measurements that is one thing another
thing I thought of is uh I mean I think
these you said this
um
uh this protocol is non-adaptive
Protocols are
asymptotically optimal is that kind of
you know
for the worst case in some sense so in
reality when you have like fixed set of
observables that you care about maybe
there's some room for improvement there
where what's what's your thoughts on
that yeah so regarding the first
question uh the first comment about the
Epson scaling I I think it's true um and
in some of the experiments that I run it
does seems like even doing randomized
experiments you can sometimes improve it
into Epsilon
um scaling in certain regime
um and we don't understand when that
happens and how does that happens yet so
I think there's definitely
um
were to be done in terms of
understanding if one could improve from
one of our Epsilon Square to one of our
Epsilon at least in certain regions I
think that's I agree on that front
um so so yeah I should take math on what
I said about things being final I think
there's still a lot to be explored
um and then regarding the second
question
um
yes
um
when we say that these randomized
measurements are asymptotically optimal
it's in a Minimax sense it's it's
basically saying that
um there exists like among this in this
problem class there exists certain
proper instances such that doing
randomized experiments is optimal but
it's not to say that you can find some
restriction of it
um such that doing things adaptively or
doing things are different from what
from this very simple protocol is
optimal and I think one example of it
that I know of is I think there's a
paper by Daniel still Franco and other
people where they consider the state to
be in a certain class for example it's
it's a gift state of some hamiltonian
and in that case I think what they could
show is that by doing these randomized
experiments
um there's a novel way of doing
measurements of doing the data
processing such that you can get a
substantial improvement asymptotically
over the
like what we prove because all these
proof about synthetic optimality they we
could have some contrived States and
then show that randomized experiment is
optimal for those contrived States I
mean but but those contracts stays like
part of the problem so you can restrict
your problem a little bit and then the
complexity could change so yes
excuse me